[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
what's the worst bomb
I bombed in Kalamazoo for 20 000 people
what 20 minutes of silence I could hear
people like what is this
how many thousand people where what what
Seinfeld no Schumer gig years ago
Kalamazoo brewed Schumer's crowd didn't
get you well it was just they it was
like we started late but you got to go
on they were half seated this guy's not
like a slot yeah there was a lot of that
I came here to talk about being a [ __ ]
I want you to do Trump talking to Amy
she's a fat pig
oh my God yesterday I was at the Netflix
as a joke Comedy Festival shout out
Netflix I did um Amy Schumer and friends
had a she has a show coming out on
Netflix where like she hosts and then
five Comics do stand up did she book you
and it's just someone uh I think she did
yeah and then I absolutely bombed on
both tapings so there's no escaping two
tapings so when you see you set both
taping same stuff how many minutes
seven minutes babe seven minutes is
tough seven minutes as well here's the
thing it was a show about the theme was
parenting okay and family and I went up
first on both shows but the theme was
family and you got that on lockdown I
proceeded to do instead because I had
just done all my family jokes on special
Western on Netflix I had not a lot of
new material so I proceeded on a family
show that Amy Schumer did jokes about
family great jokes about a family I
proceeded to do a six minute bit about
how my dog Larry died and now he was
given the wrong medication and I love
that show talked about hey babe and it
the only way that joke works is if you
laugh at the beginning then it's a
little bit of setup you laugh a little
bit in the middle and then a huge blast
at the end right and none of that
happened nobody laughed in the middle
they kind of laughed a little bit in
them nobody laughed in the beginning
subtle laughs in the middle and then the
end was a full Cricket bomb no full
Cricket bomb the first show I just got
off and was like whatever I have to do
the second show I hit the punch line
which normally gets laughs absolutely
bombed I look straight into the camera I
said I'm gonna kill myself
the crowd said nothing when you said I'm
gonna I said I said I'm gonna kill
myself and that completely lost I swear
to God who is off Pete Lee was the
warm-up commentary
dying laughing in the hallway back he
goes I can't believe you said that he
goes if Netflix has any balls they'll
keep that in I had pushed my set because
I had done the Improv changed their time
and the factory changed their time and
then I told Adam I'm gonna be late so I
was late so then my spot you know your
spot slides down and I slid down and I
said I'll still do it and it was a late
spot there was barely anybody in the
room I'm like I guess I'll just try some
new [ __ ] I get up there you know those
you know those nights when you're like
whatever there's nobody here it's like a
Tuesday
so I get up there I'm trying a bunch of
new [ __ ] it's going like mediocre but
it's fine like it's just in my head I'm
like this is fine this is exactly what I
wanted it's all it's a bunch of new
stuff I get off stage raucous I go to
sit down to look at my phone to turn off
my recorder Rock sitting next to me and
I was like [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] and I
turn and he goes hey and I was like hey
what's up yeah and I just sat there on
my phone and then before he gets up he
kind of is like you know like looking to
get up and leave without it being like
weird because we I just sat right next
to him and he kind of go turns to me and
he just goes
a good set man and then he walked away
and I was like
no he knows he knows he knows how bad it
was yeah and when you say good set man
and walk away
so now he'll remember that who that kid
yeah yeah nah did I tell you what
happened to me hit me with him at
Caroline's huh
oh my God this is the reason why I don't
play Caroline's I'll they've asked
I'll just say no because of this one
experience did you used to play it all
the time all the time I've only played
it once
so um this is before tigerbelly or bad
friends or anything I like I just didn't
have an audience yeah you did I had Mad
TV audiences but they were dwindling
sure right so I would like sell okay
tickets one show right and then it'll be
some shows it would be completely not
good right like 20 30 people right
this one particular night it was a
Saturday night second show and there's
no tickets were sold
zero I mean I had maybe 12 people
Saturday night down in New York is so
hard it's so hard and then also Michael
I remember this that night because my
friend Beth Hanley came from Long Island
because she had moved to Long Island yep
from San you know I mean I knew her from
San Diego and she um she brought her
husband and she had this you know she
had because I could see her she was like
up to the left right and this is her
face through my whole set
she's trying to read something from far
away yeah just like used and like also
like very concerned yeah like he might
need to get a job were you bombing it
was not good it was just you yeah and it
got to the because I you know
um you know I do this thing at the end
of my set let me show your penis where I
get completely naked yeah and I run
around it's the closer it's my closer
it's very humiliating they call it the
career closer
so this is so humiliated
so I have 15 minutes of my set I just
decided to do it in the middle I just
say I got to do it now in the middle of
the show I'm so I'm bombing so bad right
I don't know what the [ __ ] to do you're
like I'll just also I knew it was okay
because at the time Paul Mooney did a
third show
would I don't understand that so
um on Saturday nights Paul Mooney had
like a kind of he was a um he was like 7
10 midnight or something yeah yeah he
was like the midnight show but he came
early and they're like you can go short
because Paul's here and there's no crowd
outside to see Paul of course of course
yeah
and also you have people have to realize
that when Paul Mooney performs you know
everyone shows up no matter what city
you're in like if you're in L.A Paul
Moody performed Eddie Murphy and
everyone would show up 100 right
so um I knew Paul Moody so I go I'll
just do it now and get out and to sell
Paul's performing whatever right and I'm
on stage I'm sweating right it's cold as
[ __ ] I'm sweating yeah and and I'm naked
and no one's laughing right people are
getting up right my friend best's face
is even getting more down here like this
like anger almost and I remember just
picking up my clothes good night no
cheer right walking off and then I just
remember Sweat and Tears welling up
right and it was just terrible and you
sat in a tiny little green room they
have yeah so there's a scream up to the
left right yeah so I see a guy leaning
against the wall in the corner
uh I don't know who it is oh yeah I
don't know who it is I have my claws and
I'm walking I'm walking I'm walking
completely naked by the way right and I
realize as I get closer I go if that's
Chris Rock I swear to [ __ ] God oh no
I'm gonna quit
so I see it's a Chris oh so I go
I don't know what it says I go hey
I go hey
what up man
right I'm shaking right hey what up man
what up man and at this and what he said
to me right has been ingrained into my
psyche right it's what I wake up to it's
What I sleep with yeah
what are you doing man
you should get that tattooed on you what
are you what are you doing man and
here's my response
I don't know
I was doing a bit that was like I guess
turned out to be a somewhat uh
provocative joke like only joke I've
ever gotten death threats for but like I
was working it out there so it was even
worse I was drunk at the time yeah and
then I remember in the middle of the bed
a woman stands up it's the alligator
joke and a woman stands up and she goes
you [ __ ] stink and just paw and
everyone just is frozen and she just
walks out slams the door and uh and then
a woman goes I think you're doing great
and that [ __ ] hurt worse that hurt
worse that hurt worse cause I was like
that's pity yeah pity hate me rather
than pity oh yeah you know yeah pity
like I remember one time
small audience and a lady there was like
a table at 12 and that was like 85
percent of the audience and I'm like
just like two minutes in where you're
like you know gauging thing feeling
things out just kind of like throwing
things out she goes come on
oh and I go man what's that and she was
like come on he's helping you out
like a toddler yeah
wow
oh my god I've never heard of that one
that's another level I [ __ ] snapped
yeah and then
they leave
and then the next day the owner's like
did you
call a lady a [ __ ] I went down to Irvine
to do a guest spot Brent let me do 10
minutes I had just gotten out of a
breakup that made me punch a wall and I
was uh in the mood to try some [ __ ]
Michael anochi was hosting yeah
it was a fun night so I go up on stage
and I do a classic knock knock joke yeah
knock knock who's there yeah never mind
you guys have already heard this oh
that's okay right got some laughs go on
15 seconds later somebody goes who's
there
so I go
oh it it got the laugh it's that was
just a joke
okay keep going so uh then another
minute into uh what could be a good
enough at least set the guy goes who's
there again yeah
and I said I made a choice
which was I already asked him to stop
this guy's not gonna stop I know this
guy wants to do this thing I'm only
doing 10 minutes I like to take big
swings I I tend to find it I don't know
how quick I find it I may sabotage the
set but I got another eight minutes I'll
find it within eight minutes okay so I
used kind of the emotion that I was
feeling at the moment with the breakup
and the stuff outside of stand up and I
was I pretended I was so affected by his
who by the who's there right and I
started crying crying down the face
tears asking explaining that it was just
a knock knock joke where I was making
fun
have you ever since and then I'm like
I'm like I'm I'm so mad at him because
he's bullying me
and if you ever then I shouldn't have
done that joke whatever but now it's
worth like three minutes in and I have
to explain to you I'm making a joke if
you don't think it's funny then it's not
funny but let me just do my [ __ ]
thing
and it gets cold this guy went from he
wanted to he wanted to I don't know what
his intentions were but he was
definitely you know heckling yeah and he
went from oh I'm gonna be funny to this
and felt so bad of what he was felt that
he was doing to me I was melting down I
was melting down and in my head how
ironic imagine a guy who's literally
losing his mind over a knock knock joke
if there was any type of joke that's
funny to lose your mind over it not
working it's why did the chicken cross
the road or a knock knock joke yeah
I am now in the pocket because in my
head I'm tapped once you know once
you're once you get the watery eyes it's
it's it's easy to keep them going
I'm crying I'm bringing up bullying I'm
bringing up bullying's relevant so I'm
talking about how in high school the
stuff that was happening and how we need
to stand up for people and nowadays at
least people are able to go on YouTube
with note cards to explain their problem
but I don't have no cards thinking like
oh that's a funny bit but everyone just
thinks I'm having a panic attack so
they're just we don't want him to jump
off the stage right so I got the light
so I have about a minute left and I go
well I haven't figured it out yet so
I go and I collect myself and I wipe my
tears and I go you know what I'm sorry I
lost my cool a little bit I would like
to try the knock knock joke
will you guys give me a chance and I
don't know if you remember but before
lettuce was thrown at me yeah there was
a there was a there was a few the plates
went [ __ ] mental it was like it was
you know not for the right reason but it
was like oh you're like yeah don't jump
don't jump right right so they're
cheering so now I'm thinking got him
there is so no confident guy goes knock
knock the entire Place who's there Amos
Amos who a mosquito bit me hold hold
and I go Jesus and I just go all right
I'm sorry I'm sorry for the show it was
in Michigan too but we performed it was
the bowling alley was had uh like so
when you did the show they had to build
the stage and so you're performing
bowling allies are behind you now
they're all dark but down they still let
bowling happening so the whole show is
you're hearing bowling yeah and so I'm
opening for Big J and then uh I'm on
said they should put the stage up they
put the lights up and all this and so
I'm doing the thing and the crowd's like
sitting there and uh you know you're
sitting in the crowds like sitting in
like seats like they had like actually
kind of stadium seating because I think
they do like bowling competitions there
and so they had kind of stadium seating
and then tables but the stadium seating
was empty no one's there everybody's
just kind of down at the tables and it
is a lot of room I mean it's basically
you're a whole bowling alley is kind of
shut down for you except at the end and
so when I'm up there the spotlight goes
out so I'm just in the dark whole set
I'm just in the dark and so I'm like you
know talking I'm like I'm making jokes
about the guy comes over brings the
ladder climbs up with the ladder fixes
the uh the spotlight comes back down
ladder everybody claps like all right do
it again Bubba and then uh
within three minutes the light goes out
again and I'm like ah I got to fix it
again there he goes all right and he
goes to get the ladder that he put back
the ladders at the other end of the ball
he put it back
all the way back and I mean it's like a
10 minutes for him to come back with a
letter and it's and there's a ton of
room that you want to go just leave the
ladder that guy's confident in his work
he was confident because this light will
never go out and everybody just left
he's like why would you not Emmit just
that ladder hits yeah Mike just on he's
up there having to fix it
uh that's my bowling all history I love
that there's just a couple of lanes open
they're like yeah we're doing a show but
we need a little bowling I was doing a
college gig something called the nooner
so it was basically like you know in a
cafeteria during the middle of the day
nobody has any idea there's going to be
a show and you get like the worst intro
you know you always do the credits first
he's been on this he's been on that but
please welcome so they would always do
your name first and they would just be
like we have a comedian his name is Bill
Burr he's been on TV and here he is and
then he will just go out and immediately
would just be bombing and kids were
eating so like I went up there really
defensive it was somewhere in the middle
of the country and I just went up there
just chopping people's heads off because
I thought they wouldn't throw food at me
so I just started attacking the crowd
how long how long are you gonna do it I
did well I was supposed to do like an
hour I did like 20 minutes I remember
one I couldn't believe it didn't get a
laugh there was a guy with a cowboy hat
wearing a suit and I go to this guy
looks like he's trying to get a loan for
a horse
and it got nothing it's a good joke it
was all right it got nothing
and then I just it was too like I don't
know what and then all of a sudden it's
just student came up and handed me that
note and that was the woman that booked
me said can you wrap it up in five
minutes so then I was thinking wait a
minute I'm contractually obligated to do
an hour is this how they get out of
paying me
so I was on stage in the cafeteria no
laughs going are you still gonna pay me
I still get paid it was the uh PR uh
unions uh uh benefit yeah celebrating
Kirk Douglas at the Beverly Hills Hotel
this was you know um a few years ago
about eight nine years ago and if you
know anything about Kirk Douglas besides
playing Spartacus and being an academy
award-winning actor and the father of
Michael Douglas
he he suffered uh 20 years before from a
stroke a horrible stroke which kind of
but they don't tell you that they don't
know ing on that well and he couldn't
speak he lost his his ability to uh
speak clearly they also don't tell you
it's not even on the card it's the whole
function and there's like so he gets on
his answering machine Theo Von somebody
saw you on TV and somebody saw you in
another show and they said you'd be
perfect for it you're really funny
you're witty
we would love you to come to the Beverly
Hills Hotel
and host
uh the Kirk Douglas benefit yeah and uh
Theo doesn't you know he's busy
um yes well he did say yes but I don't
think he heard the word host he heard
roast
[Laughter]
he heard roast I
Syria and when when this was happening I
was with him he was legitimately upset
he goes to the hotel
and who are some of the people that are
there in the audience and
Sally Field was there and I didn't know
if it was Sally Field or fields
and he didn't know Kirk Douglas had a
stroke yeah well here's the thing they
just you know you think Publix is guilt
they [ __ ] give you some Intel right
so I had nothing bro they sent me out
there and I thought it was a roast so we
wrote all these Rose jokes me and my
friend Matt Weiss wrote The Rose jokes
about
Kirk Douglas yeah
and
the man is like 95 years old he can't
speak didn't you call attention to that
in the roast how good an actor is he he
can't even everything's a vowel
didn't you say that he doesn't have one
[ __ ] consonant and then you get up to
do the roast listen to this guy
and what happened oh he said uh what do
we say man we said
we said oh I his publicist job must be
easy
um he's still alive that's just her
announcement every year
we ripped he was 90 something years old
you know and so I thought it was a roast
for how for uh how old he was whatever
his name was Harold Douglas so I get
there dude and I've been out the night
before bro I wasn't even really doing
that great and so I get over there wrote
all these jokes
the craziest part was one joke there's
one guy that laughs right the lights are
off in there right one guy that laughs
and it's a black guy laughing right I
grew up in a black neighbor I know a
black eye laugh from a white guy laugh
unless it's Lester Holt but there was a
guy in the room that was laughing that
you were sure was black and it was nice
one laugh goes it's one laugh bro
there's a thousand people in there so
when I finally get a laugh
and I think the Joker maybe Ben had a
little right some racial undertone so
the one that he laughs is black and I'm
like at least the brother laughed for me
right I said that right so for some
reason they bring the lights up as if we
need to see if it's a black eye oh my
God the only thing that went right in
the whole production is that at some
point when I mentioned that that's a
black guy laughing they bring the
[ __ ] lights off and and it was
it was Lester Holtz the one black guy
they invited to the thing found enjoyed
it but didn't but didn't they come up
and stop you oh yeah they shut me down
didn't Sally Fields come up and stop you
and say what Sally Field was good who oh
I remember this was the craziest part so
it kept going bad you know and nobody
was telling me nothing man you know and
you're roasting Kirk Douglas oh I'm
roasting everybody they had a couple oh
this is the worst part they had a couple
children from like Siam or something
that came in with some documentary and I
roasted those bags
I didn't know what was going on
but it was no rehearsal I didn't even
know what the [ __ ] this thing was
yeah it's rusted oh stinging man and
everybody's eating out there eating
salmon bruh and uh and the worst part
was I went backstage Robert Downey Jr's
back there with um
the guy I want to say Corbin burnson is
that a man yeah okay it is a man and a
white man yes yeah and a white man so
Corbin burnson and how uh and uh Robert
Downey Robert Downey Jr or standing
backstage and this is before Iron Man
this is when he had just I think messed
with the hookers or something okay or
the men whatever happened I don't know
who didn't do him I don't know what it
was man oh when he got high and then he
woke up in somebody else's house yeah
whatever you want to call it okay we've
all got different version of game
Chicken we've all used I'm backstage
he's back there oh this is what happened
he goes
and they knew it was going bad
they knew it was going bad I mean you
know what's bad when Iron Man shows up
right
let's just stop everything
and he goes hey man in 10 years nobody
will remember
the funniest thing you watch as a
comedian is watching another comedian
die on stage and the reason why is that
that's something that you relate to so
innately so personally that it makes me
personally just laugh so hard because
you have that experience and nobody
knows it better than a comedian or a
performer that just completely dies on
so you just laugh because you relate to
it so hard it's not because like oh I'm
happy he's bombing no no it's like this
when he's going through his mindset all
the [ __ ] that's going through his head
the catastrophizing the [ __ ] scene
the breakdown in the middle of the road
you can't get out of it he's looking for
the light have I been lit yet that [ __ ]
is like classic man my first three years
I used to break chairs well I used to
break bottles and hit a pigeon with a
car oh my god when I bombed I would get
so
I have to learn how to bond with Grace
right that was the big problem I had the
first
three years the other thing that I had a
lot of other Comics didn't have is I
know when I bomb right there's nothing
worse to see an economy come off stage
you know you're like oh god what the
[ __ ] is wrong oh no that's the worst
yeah denial I destroyed that room you
know like I was sitting in the back I
had to take a tomato from a guy yes it
was just about to [ __ ] hit me with a
slingshot oh easy you're telling me
that's the other retardation yeah you
don't want to say nothing I can't do I
love when I bomb and you're standing
there having a drink and you won't make
it and to break the eye contact I know
how bad was that bomb again makes the
Gulf War look like a [ __ ] Chinese
parade
there's 10 shows in my life that almost
ruined you that that there was oh I had
a [ __ ] show at Cobbs Al magical saw
it where I went to the kitchen and I
literally got on my hands and knees and
I and I looked up in the sky and just
cried it was that terrible Natasha
leggera was there that's just oh God
I mean there's there's ten of them in my
life that stays with me
shows forever they were so bad yeah and
and they're always like situations where
um it could have ruined me like that
show with it at Cobbs yeah was
Zuckerberg it was for Facebook what yeah
so Facebook was rented out cobs and they
get us the best Comics it was me Ian
Edwards Natasha Leggero out magical
and I thought they said the best Comics
back in the all right come on
but at the time yeah no no great yeah it
was good all good very good comments and
so um and I had to close right but by
that time they were drunk yeah and I
just remember like it people were
dancing like there's music playing for
some reason I'm on stage and people are
just like the party has started people
were just Zuckerberg everyone's just
dancing right yeah I'm going to tell my
jokes right people are just dancing not
even paying attention right I remember
just putting the mic back in going
getting my knees and just screaming
crying crying in the kitchen oh my God
it was terrible I bet you can play there
again
foreign
[Music]